I have seen the first three episodes and
my only comment is Fu for not giving me
four through six sorry because I would
really like to see where this is all
going I'm gonna design that way right
this is sort of like an old cereal where
you know it's really propulsive the
episodes are like 35 to 40 minutes they
play very quickly and then we try to
hook you at the end and push it but
that's the problem you have hooked me
good and it's like the dope it worked
you know it worked so um before I I have
a million questions for the show but I
know I'm going to run out of time in two
seconds so I want to know when it's
gonna start uh so what you are in
post-production on the movie you've just
shot that's right do you already know
what you're doing next no we're in that
we're in that place where we're
developing several things and uh you
know there's a potential looming Rider
strike there are things that could
affect uh timeline uh but
um uh we're going to develop these
different projects and then make a
decision yeah it has ask us this summer
I have a feeling like this summer we'll
figure it out uh when will I see footage
from Electric State oh boy I don't know
I mean it's a electric state is a very
visual effect heavy movie
um so it's it's it's a it's a slow one
ninety percent of the characters are CG
so it is a it's gonna take a little time
to bake it so basically summer of 2024
or Beyond I think that's probably Fair
yeah I think Fair estimate yeah exactly
um so one of the things jumping into the
show one of the things that I really am
looking forward to is that you're doing
different versions in other countries
you know you have one in India you have
one in Italy
um I'm curious this obviously with with
the American version the first episode
has movie style action uh on a
television show yeah will the other
countries have that kind of
amplification you know what I mean where
it's big and propulsive I mean yes I
think that you know the ambition is
large for all the shows but we don't
want that to become a you know the
dominant uh um driving Factor behind the
show somebody could come to us and Pitch
an idea that takes place in a one room
for seven episodes and you know it it
could be incredibly compelling like that
should be the opportunity from these uh
Regional shows is to shift tone to shift
scale to go in directions that we're not
expecting so that they're all just not a
you know a replicant of each other I
mean the the common theme is it all it
is all set in the Spy World right it's
all there's all an element of spy
Thriller to all the shows but we are
very much trying to find the variety of
ways we can explore that stylistically
and narratively the first season is six
episodes which of the six episodes are
you most looking forward to audiences
soon I think that's sixth episode and
that's you know what's great about the
show is that it was designed like you
know an onion you're peeling back the
layers of it and you know we use these
twisting shots throughout the show just
to represent you know when when the
narrative is upside down and that you
can't you know you don't you can't trust
anything that you see and I think it
goes to a really powerful climax yeah
that's what your lead actors said it was
like episode six yeah which is why of
course I haven't seen it I'm I'm going
to keep teasing you on this
um what are you at one of the things
talk a little bit about the first
episode though because I was very
impressed it is a movie style action set
piece on a TV show and I know how hard
those are to pull off very difficult
yeah so talk a little bit about uh make
why did you want the first episode to
have an action set piece like that and
also talk about filming it well you
wanna you wanna announce your show out
of the gate you want to you know grab
the audience quickly and that was always
the intention uh uh with the shows that
it would have cinematic scale to it
um and Amazon's been incredible about
supporting the show and it's applying
the right resources infrastructure to do
that
um but uh but you know the uh also
you know we like playing a genre or
maybe we you know we we don't uh
um mince words in that regard we grew up
loving genre and the way that we play in
it is that we present it to you as you
know it and then we try to slowly
subvert it or add emotion to it or
surprise you uh playing against you know
your expectations and I think this show
does that really well so the setup at
the beginning is to make you feel like
you're in a traditional large-scale
Global spy Thriller and then as it as it
unfolds we twist we twist The Narrative
on you and take you to places you're not
expecting I don't know if you want to
add anything no I mean I mean look at
Again part of it is just trying to to up
the Annie with what's possible outside
of a theater you know sure one I'm
curious so you go in and you pitch with
Amazon and you're talking about the show
how much do they want to know well if it
you know assuming everything is great
which they're obviously investing a lot
of money in this that you have the plan
already for Season Two Season three you
sort of know where you're going and how
much is it sort of like well you guys
have a good track record I mean like
that that was one of the amazing things
that we have such a long relationship
with Jen saki we have a very high level
of trust with her so she could call us
with a with a basically a business model
of like hey
Amazon Has This Global reach we have
amazing uh uh presence and in so many
markets around the world like can you
come up with a narrative that would use
creative teams throughout the world in
an interconnected way a collaborative
way like that was it she could throw
that idea to us and it was our job to
come up with a story that was worthy of
that kind of a format you know so that's
really been our process with Amazon from
the beginning uh it's just coming to
them with story and look while there is
a really high concept clever concept at
work here it's like when we did the
Marvel films it's the same thing you're
learning as you go you sort of you're
beating ideas as you go so for as much
as we know about where things are going
we're constantly Reinventing where
things can go Italy and India are
different timelines you want to be
available to how they may affect or
change the show we have loose ideas of
where this is all going but you you have
to say organic and fluid what is the
status of a second season of Citadel
nothing confirmed yet everything's in
the audience's hands at this point we'll
we'll find out in you know 10 days or a
week or whatever it is from now I am I'm
going to go back to the beginning of
this interview when you said you had a
few things you're thinking about is it
like two is it three is it like how are
these projects you've been developing
for a while yeah yeah I mean here's the
thing just like electric State we're in
a phase now where
we are uh when we started agbo a few
years ago we went to work with Marcus
and mcfeely sort of doing a deep dive on
some original
um storytelling and um the electric
state was kind of part of that effort
it's it was a complicated story to
figure out it took a lot of years to
figure it out so what we're dealing with
right now is the stuff that we've
invested a few years in and we've been
playing with for a while now and we're
you know and it it's generally more
complicated uh elaborate World building
it was that takes time to develop so
that's kind of what we're playing with
you know that there's some long-form
stories that we're working on as well
it's nice to you know we've spent our
career jumping around from Comedy to
Drama TV to film uh
um and we like to surprise ourselves
with what we do next and there's a
couple long-form ideas that that could
also make sense on that note I'm just
going to say send me episodes four
through six and have a good day